good afternoon i'm assistant sheriff
andrew walsh and i'm here today to brief
you on the additional details as we know
them today about the officer-involved
shooting that took place on tuesday
october 12 2021.
this is officer-involved shooting number
eight for 2021 it's fatal event number
five
at the same time last year we had 16
officer-involved shootings eight of
which were fatal
this event was initiated by an assault
and battery with a firearm at 0-9-33
hours on october 12 2021
the address of the original call was in
the 5600 block of east lake mead
the officer-involved shooting occurred
near the intersection of sloan lane and
east charleston boulevard las vegas
nevada 89156
which is located in the southeast area
command and you can see that area
depicted on the map on the screen to my
left
the involved officer in this incident is
officer ramon highstand
ramon is 35 years old and he's been with
the lvmpd since 2014.
in this incident officer high stand was
armed with a cult le carbine 223 caliber
rifle equipped with a tactical light
and the investigation revealed he fired
eight rounds during this incident
orvis high stand is assigned to the
community policing division which is
within the community i'm sorry which is
within the southeast area command
and the suspect in this incident was
identified as mario lawrence martinez
he was a 43 year old hispanic male adult
he was 5 foot 10 and he weighed 260
pounds and he was pictured on the screen
to my left
in this incident martinez was armed with
a semi-automatic
s-c-c-y nine-millimeter handgun and the
investigation revealed he fired five
rounds during this incident two of those
rounds were fired while martinez was
kidnapping the victim from her apartment
and the rest of the rounds were fired at
the officer-involved shooting scene
had martinez survived he would have been
charged with kidnapping with a deadly
weapon attempted murder five counts of
attempted murder on a police officer
home invasion burglary with a firearm
and shooting into an occupied structure
and the details of the officer-involved
shooting are as follows
on tuesday october 25
tuesday october 12 2021 the lvmpd
dispatch center received a call from a
citizen reporting a shooting in a
four-plex apartment building located in
the 5600 block of east lake mead
boulevard the caller also stated that
the shooting was related to a domestic
violence incident
officers arrived and contacted a man in
front of the apartments the man
explained to the officers that this
apartment is where he and his girlfriend
live and he went on to explain how his
girlfriend's ex-boyfriend mario lawrence
martinez had been harassing them
he told officers that martinez came over
and fired shots before kicking in the
front door of the apartment
martinez entered the apartment and
forcibly removed his girlfriend
threatening her with a handgun
martinez attempted to leave the area
using the female's victim's vehicle
however her vehicle had a dead battery
martinez then forced the victim to walk
with him away from the apartment
building
patrol officers were able to determine
that martinez was likely heading to his
residence which was not far from the
lake mead address
a description of martinez and the victim
was broadcast to all officers in the
area
at approximately 10 50 a.m patrol
officers saw martinez and the victim
walking in the area of charleston
boulevard and sloan lane
officers tried to get martinez to
release the victim and asked him to
surrender
martinez failed to comply with the
officer's commands and began moving away
while holding the victim at gunpoint and
walked into a busy shopping center
parking lot
martinez attempted to steal a car that
was in a restaurant drive-thru and
martinez was unsuccessful in that
attempt and he also tried to steal two
other vehicles in the parking lot those
attempts were also unsuccessful
he then forced the victim to walk into a
grocery store with him while he was
still holding her at gunpoint and waving
the gun in the air
martinez made his way through the
grocery store and eventually exited the
store into the rear alley
throughout martinez's movements officers
followed and were in close proximity to
him and the victim
there was an unoccupied box truck which
you see in the picture to my left parked
to the rear of the grocery store
martinez shot out the window of that
vehicle and he attempted to steal it and
attempted to force the victim into it
he was unable to start the truck and
force the victim to walk with him
westbound in the alley towards sloan
lane while all this was happening
responding officers were setting up
containment around the shopping center
and as martinez was making his way
westbound toward sloan a team of
officers was already posted in the alley
which included officer ramon high stand
as martinez reached the sidewalk on the
east side of sloan lane he pointed his
firearm at officers
the victim then took this opportunity to
break away from martinez and officer
heist and then fired his rifle at
martinez striking him causing him to
fall to the ground when martinez fell to
the ground he began firing shots from
his handgun toward the officers officer
high stand returned fire and then
martinez stopped shooting officers moved
in to render aid however martinez was
pronounced deceased at the scene by
medical personnel and now we're going to
show you some body-worn camera footage
and we're also going to show you some
surveillance footage that we've
recovered so far during this from this
event
so this is video from the fast food
drive-through you can see martinez
wearing the blue shirt and there's the
victim standing behind him as he
attempts to gain entry into that vehicle
while holding the gun
and then what you'll see shortly is
martinez walks back towards that vehicle
and then he points his firearm
downrange in the parking lot at
responding officers to the
to this parking lot area
so you can see it's a crowded parking
lot
suspect forcibly holding the victim
and in this next video
what you're going to see is you can see
the victim and the suspect walking
towards this white suv that's pulling
down the
lane
the suspect drags the victim to the
passenger side of the vehicle attempts
to gain entry but the driver of the
vehicle is able to speed away
and it's at this point
where martinez takes the victim and
drags her into the supermarket
so the next
segment of this you'll see
the suspect and the victim entered the
store you can see
the firearm
and in here the suspect and the victim
are circled
and you see an officer using shopping
carts to block
the exit
and you see other officers in the right
of the screen
and then this is after
the suspect was unsuccessful in
stealing the box truck
he's going to come walking into view
here in a second
and you can see how he's holding the
victim at gunpoint using her as a shield
and this is in the alley as i described
earlier walking westbound towards sloane
and this is body one camera footage
from officer high stand
so the area you want to pay attention to
is along the wall
you'll get a glimpse of the
suspect and the victim
okay
[Music]
and this video that you're going to see
now is from the air unit
so again walking westbound
in the alley
okay
so slow down you see
she gets to walk away he raises the
firearm towards the officers and for
obvious reasons we're not going to show
the rest of that event
and that concludes this briefing
yeah obviously you see the drive-through
uh no calls from the people in the
drive-through
no calls we have calls from the
albertsons but no calls from
folks outside the second vehicle that
drives off no calls so you know people
should call us when they see something
like that i mean it's kind of sad when
you see a victim being dragged around at
gunpoint we don't get more calls than we
got we got some but not the amount that
you would think we got
do you know if martinez has any previous
history of
so as always in these press briefings we
tell you you can get their criminal
history from records
but between this
and this incident we don't know that
there's any history of domestic violence
between him and the victim
yes
she had some marks
from him holding her and she had an
injury to the back of her head which she
said was caused by the suspect
thankfully no and i appreciate you
asking
was this situation just because it was
just a moving scene from place to place
how dangerous was that for your officers
to try to make sure that they weren't
shooting someone in the background yeah
it's a great question i'm glad you asked
it because it really gives people an
indication of what
especially in our community what their
police department and what their
officers trained for and what they're
capable of
i think in this incident you know it's
it's really a
nightmare scenario of a mobile hostage
situation
but thankfully
the citizen
that was kidnapped was not hurt and
thankfully none of our officers were
hurt and no other citizens were hurt you
know the loss of life obviously in any
situation is sad and tragic for the
family members of that person involved
but in this situation the suspect
dictated the actions of the officers and
there was little left for us to do
all right thank you very much
you